why was newton a complicated man
we're breaking news today this is like
uh
right
complicated it's like
his brain structure was different i
don't know why he had a complicated
young life as we've said
um
he
had always been
very
self-contained and solitary he had
acquaintances in france
and when he moved to london eventually
he had quite a career
a career for instance that led him when
he was famous by then the 1690s he moves
to london he becomes first
warden of the mint the mint is what
produces coins and coinage was a
complicated thing because there was
counterfeiting going on
and he becomes master of the mint to the
extent
and a guy at mit
wrote a book about this a little bit we
wrote something on it too i forget his
name was levin
um that newton sent
investigators out to catch these guys
and sent at least one of them a famous
one named challenger to the gallows
so he was
he and and one of the reasons he
probably was so particularly angry at
challenger was challenger had apparently
said some nasty things about newton in
front of parliament at some point
fair enough yeah that was apparently not
a good idea well he had a bit of a ten
percent had a bit of a clearly okay
you